donc pour les faits george best était à
la tête de la régie renault depuis
janvier 85 il avait d'abord été l'un des
patrons du nucléaire français à la dette
d'eurodif et de la cogema et puis
ensuite il avait dirigé pechiney enfin
ils avaient été appelés donc en 85 à la
tête de la régie renault pour redresser
une situation difficile jean pierre
métivier c'est en sauveur que georges
besse arrive à la tête de la régie
renault en chantier 85 l'entreprise à 12
milliards de pertes lui a une solide
réputation de gestionnaire acquise chez
péchiney georges besse à 58 ans c'est
aussi un des grands hommes du nucléaire
l'ex président de la cogema il a
construit pierrelatte et tricastin à la
régie il surprend tout le monde en se
taisant pendant un an il ne dit rien il
travaille il n'intervient qu'au rythme
des séances des comités d'entreprise
cela lui vaut l'hostilité des syndicats
de la régie et aussi des militants
communistes qui l'interpellent ici sur
les champs elysées à la sortie d'un
conseil d'administration
pourtant c'est lui qui décide les
premiers licenciements secs chez renault
qui reprend en main le réseau commercial
et y réussit ces derniers mois une
remontée des ventes
non seulement faux mais également de
structure lors du dernier salon il
pouvait annoncer que les pertes de la
régie n'atteindrait que 5 milliards et
demi cette année la chance lui souriait
lui aussi avait retrouvé son sourire il
avait même donné rendez vous aux enfants
comme moi parce qu'obligés une renault 5
quant à elle est très agréable parce que
ça permet de rouler comme on veut cela
permet de cigarettes